I I just made a couple notes first of  all I want to thank my family my friends  the incredible people of Chicago and all  over the country in the world who have  prayed for me who have supported me  who've shown me so much love no one will  ever know how much that has meant to me  and I will forever be grateful I want  you to know that not for a moment was it  in vain  I've been truthful and consistent on  every single level since day one I would  not be my mother's son if I was capable  of one drop of what I was accused of  this has been an incredibly difficult  time honestly one of the worst of my  entire life but I am a man of faith and  I'm a man that has knowledge of my  history and I would not bring my family  our lives or the movement through a fire  like this  I just wouldn't so I want to thank my  legal counsel from the bottom of my  heart and I would also like to thank the  state of Illinois for attempting to do  what's right